alors regardé ce film tourné au centre
beaugrenelle qui nous a accueillis très
gentiment un jour de mauvais temps la
caméra cachée tourner ces jours ci dans
paris je ne parle pas français
pouvez-vous indiquer la prostate le
cancer alors
l'atout trois messieurs là là tout droit
vers une théorie qui monte dans aux
latéraux montés aux poudres à la maison
causse
oui oui oui oui mais vous comprenez
puisque vous parlez sans vous l'écris
vrai nom sympa et du coup la dame écrit
oui sur le papier de jacques legras oui
mais si oui oui et vous allez voir
maintenant la dame ne va pas remarqué
comme jacques legras se met à parler
français c'est à dire que je je vais à
la poste la poste à la vieillesse est
alors ensuite je peux envoyer un
télégramme umaga étendue oui assez bien
ce que c'est bien je vous avais marre
qu'ils étaient des timbres étrangers ici
il ya dix vivent des drames
les projections de sanyo oui je penserai
lance le labour et ouais mais vous
parlez vous savez que vous pouvez pas
penser ça c'est pour faire et là c'est
le french france vous écrivez vous pas
vous pensez que c'est pas là elle fait
ce prix vous pouvez vous pouvez monter
par la lasse elle
oui bien sûr et par français a cassé
pourrait alors là je pourrais leur
demander en français ils me répondront
en fait un bond qui fêtera vous disiez
que la poste française domaine avant
avant mairie donc je peux le sait pas
besoin d'écrire alors vous demandez vous
trouvez la poste je peux leur parler de
vous en prenant ce sans problème il n'y
a rien d'extraordinaire
quand vous avez commencé que j'ai si
bien mais je ne sais pas et il comprend
pas le
il ne parle pas il l'écrit parfaitement
bien mais je n'ai jamais écrit des trucs
cochons
la plupart des gens parlent pas anglais
avec un étranger accès pourrait rester
assez assez
chou chou et olivier nakache avoir de
nombreuses familles riches un autre gros
neige le vent neige
c'est environ 10 à 70 à 80 en 200 ça
c'est interdit chez cris amplement
disent yes
ça se passait tout ça c'est français ça
c'est dur on dit aussi qu'ils vivent les
français et françaises je comprends très
bien le français
interrogé le bureau de poste pour nous
la chose contre hand français mais
parfaitement je l'avais du pitztal bon
il doit y avoir un bureau de poste mais
seulement et signe de demander à
quelqu'un dit si je suis pas d'ici là
oui oui mais je retiens ça vous
comprenez il demande de france décrit
non pour conseil
oui c'est la langue de bondy sincèrement
non oui parce que c'est actuellement
participe à l'émission de caméra cachée
pour antenne 2 nous sommes filmés pour
antennes direct
oui mais lequel mark allemand